some of the most popular TV shows of all
time almost never had the chance to find
a fan base as the network's nearly
canceled them and other hits actually
were cancelled before gaining an
unexpected second life here's a look at
some of the most popular TV shows that
were so close to being canceled forever
it turns out friends was almost not
there for you co-creator David Crane
recently explained to the Huffington
Post that the show which went on to run
for 10 seasons and ranks as one of the
most watched programs in US history
didn't test well at first apparently it
was considered to be geared towards too
young of an audience had too many sexual
innuendos and featured characters that
were only moderately likable to test
audiences NBC viewed it as a lackluster
effort but didn't have much else to fall
back on for its fall schedule and crane
and co-creator Marta Kauffman stood by
their concept crane said the show was
always the six friends and we were
prepared to live or die by that that is
how God intended it despite its critical
acclaim and a small but dedicated fan
following NBC's community was
dangerously close to being cancelled in
the middle of its third season as the
network put the show on hiatus with no
return date mentioned in its promotional
materials fans of the series eventually
succeeded in pressing for a renewal of
the show it ran for two more seasons at
NBC before being picked up by Yahoo
screen to avoid yet another cancellation
scare finishing out its sixth season on
the digital platform the show did not
return for a seventh season but it has
long boasted itself as a six seasons in
a movie experience so a feature film
follow-up is still spinning in the rumor
mill we wait a little bit let them
explore their their awsome careers and
then we get together for an incredible
movie in another instance of NBC almost
under estimating its TV gold reserves
with a premature cancellation the
network reportedly only signed on for a
four episode order of what was then
titled the Seinfeld Chronicles according
to Business Insider Rick Ludwin who
headed up late-night programming for the
network ultimately convinced execs to
produce four more episodes and rerun the
pilot which then received significantly
higher ratings and justified ordering a
second season
Seinfeld ultimately ran for nine seasons
and was the most watched TV show from
1994 to 1995 and 1997 to 1998
you're very funny Jerry that's what I
always tell people Jerry Seinfeld's a
funny guy the story of the Dillon Texas
football teams with clear eyes and full
hearts almost did lose after its second
season ratings were low enough to
justify its early cancellation on NBC
but just like the Panthers the network
showed some serious heart by negotiating
a deal with DIRECTV to co-produce its
third fourth and fifth seasons on
DIRECTV's 101 Network instead of cutting
it altogether
you got to get the fans involved you
know like sometimes people mail stuff to
network to show how passionate they are
they sent light bulbs to save Friday
Night Lights the show is now a cult
favorite and was a notable critical
success despite its less than ideal
audience numbers it's gonna get that
going for me anyway in another case of
an original series fan base pulling out
all of the creative stops to get a
network to greenlight another season
followers of HBO's critically acclaimed
but ratings plague drama series the
leftovers showed up at the network's
headquarters in New York City dressed as
the show's guilty remnant faction a
group of people who we're all white
chain-smoke and wordlessly picket events
as a form of civil disobedience
according to Variety HBO citing their
respect for such fan enthusiasm and
commitment to creator Damon Lindelof
vision for closing out the series
renewed it for a third and final season
which brought the story to its
preordained conclusion so this is the
last time we're ever gonna see each
other huh what do you mean she's the
world ascending okay in another instance
of a series being rescued from its
network's dustbin Fox's Arrested
Development was shelved after three
seasons thanks to a ratings dip in the
second season and a continued decline in
season three before it was ultimately
canceled but fans of the quirky comedy
series made their hopes for more
perfectly clear leading to Netflix
purchasing the rights in producing a
highly touted fourth season for its own
originals lineup in 2013 a fifth season
followed in 2018 why do you say it
Michael
[Music]